your Majesties your royal highness
excellencies ladies and gentlemen now I
have the pleasure to invite the Nobel
Peace Prize laureate of 1991 to come
forward to give us her lecture we do not
have a gold medal because it was
received by your son Alexander in 1991
but I'm sure that your words to us today
will be written in gold please
your Majesties your royal highness
excellencies distinguished members of
the Nobel Committee dear friends
long years ago sometimes it seems many
lives ago I was at Oxford listening to
the radio program Desert Island Discs
with my young son Alexander it was a
well-known program for all I knew it
still continues on rich famous people
from all walks of life were invited to
talk about the eight disks the one book
beside the Bible and the complete works
of Shakespeare and the one luxury item
they would wish to have with them were
they to be marooned on a desert island
at the end of the program which we had
both enjoyed Alexander asked me if I
thought I might ever be invited to speak
on Desert Island Discs why not I
responded lightly since he knew that in
general only celebrities took part in
the program he proceeded to ask me with
genuine interest why I thought I might
be invited I considered this for a
moment and then answered perhaps because
I'd have won the Nobel Prize for
Literature and we both laughed
the prospect seemed pleasant but hardly
probable I cannot now remember why I
gave that answer perhaps because I'd
recently read a book by a Nobel laureate
or perhaps because the della Desert
Island celebrity of that day had been a
famous writer in 1989 when my late
husband Michael Aris came to see me
during my first term of house arrest he
told me that a friend John finis had
nominated me for the Nobel Peace Prize
this time I also laughed for an instant
Michael looked amazed then he realized
why I was amused the Nobel Peace Prize a
pleasant prospect but quite in
so how did I feel when I was actually
awarded the Nobel Prize for Peace the
question has been put to me many times
and this is surely the most appropriate
occasion on which to examine but the
Nobel Prize means to me and what peace
means to me as I have said repeatedly
and so met in many an interview I heard
the news that I had been awarded the
Nobel Peace Prize on the radio one
evening it did not altogether come as a
surprise because I had been mentioned as
one of the frontrunners for the prize in
a number of broadcasts during the
previous week while drafting this
lecture I have tried very hard to
remember what my immediate reaction to
the announcement of the award had been I
think I can no longer be sure I think it
was something like oh so this does
they've decided to give it to me it did
not seem quite real because in a sense I
did not feel myself to be quite real at
that time often during my days of house
arrest it felt as though I would no
longer part of the real world there was
a house which was my world there was a
world of others who also were not free
but who were together in prison as a
community and there was the world of the
free each one was a different planet
pursuing its own separate course in an
indifferent universe but the Nobel Peace
Prize did was to draw me once again into
the world of other human beings outside
the isolated area in which I lived to
restore a sense of reality to me this
did not happen instantly of course but
as the days and months went by and news
of reactions to the award came over the
airwaves I began to understand the
significance of the Nobel Prize it had
made me real once again it had drawn me
back into the wider human community and
what is more important the Nobel Prize
had drawn the attention of the world to
the struggle for democracy and human
rights in Burma we were not going to be
forgotten